ce matin des réunions de groupes
politiques à partir de 10h30 10h45
maximum voilà c'est le ministre c'est à
vous merci d'être là merci beaucoup
monsieur le président la commission des
lois à madame la présidente de la
commission des affaires sociales
monsieur le rapporteur
de la commission des lois madame la
rapporteure pour avis mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs ne sait pas donc
la première fois que je me présente
devant vous je crois que c'est la 11e
fois que je me présente devant vous dans
le cadre
d'une audition sur la gestion de crise
sanitaire
avec un projet de loi qui annonce la
couleur il s'agit plus d'état d'urgence
sanitaire mais bien de vigilance
sanitaire
et pour cause j'ai connu et pourquoi
j'ai connu des contextes où je me
présenter devant vous alors que les
hôpitaux se remplissait que les cas se
comptaient par dizaines de milliers et
que nous étions sur le point de mettre
en place de décréter où l'état d'urgence
localisé ou nationales ou des mesures de
confinement cette fois ci la situation
est différente et pour autant elle
impose cette vigilance sanitaire
que je viens plaidé devant vous devant
vous ce matin
la situation est différente parce
qu'effectivement nous sommes à 5000 cas
de circulation de virus par jour et qu'
il n'y a pas une charge hospitalière qui
soit aussi intense que celle que nous
avons connue et pour autant
avons-nous
devant nous des perspectives de
réductions d'épidémie voir d'écrasement
du virus la réponse est non en tout cas
ni à court ni à moyen terme j'en veux
pour preuve ce qui se passe en europe
vous savez sans doute toute l'europe est
soumise à une augmentation de la
pression épidémique en europe de l'est
là où la vaccination est bien plus
faible qu'en europe de l'ouest l'impact
sanitaire est réel et intense avec des
pays qui affichent des taux d'incidence
extrêmement élevé plus de 700 pour pour
100000 habitants sur sur sept jours je
pense à la roumanie notamment la
lettonie d'autres pays la bulgarie la
slovénie et en europe occidentale
il ya le cas anglais avec une
vaccination qui est insuffisante de la
population l'arrêt de toute mesure vous
le savez de gestion de de la crise
décision qui a été prise au niveau
politique de faire comme si le virus
finalement n'engendrerait plus de dégâts
et la basse et du 45000 et bientôt du
cinquante mille cas par jour qui sont
enregistrés avec une charge hospitalière
qui commence quand même à poser des
questions d'ailleurs qui commence à être
soulevées au plus haut niveau de l'état
en angleterre vont-ils pouvoir célébrer
les fêtes de fin d'année ne vont-ils pas
devoir finalement mettre en place un
système de passes tu à lithaire
disposent ces questions parce qu'il voit
bien que la croissance épidémique risque
de ne pas s'y arrêter et qui n'en
maîtrisent plus les tenants et
aboutissants avec une couverture
vaccinale qui est plus faible que chez
nous nos voisins allemands considèrent
souvent en exemple qui ont une
couverture vaccinale qui est plus faible
que chez nous ont dépassé les 13 14
mille cas certains jours ils sont en
phase de croissance épidémie qu'ils ont
un taux d'incidence qui est plus élevé
que le nôtre belgique pays bas tous les
pays qui nous entourent à l'exception
notable pour l'instant des pays du sud
de l'europe mais parce que de quoi
parlons nous nous parlons de conditions
climatiques plus humide est plus froide
qui sont propices à des circulations
tous les virus notamment les virus
respiratoires telles que la grippe le
vrs qui donne la bronchiolite bientôt la
gastro entérite que les français
connaissent bien et donc le coc vide et
nourrit je dirais est logé à la même
enseigne et donc dans l'europe du sud
les conditions climatiques sont encore
un peu plus favorable et un peu moins
propice à la circulation des virus mais
nul doute que l'espagne et l'italie
connaîtront prochainement une croissance
épidémies comme la nôtre je dis qu'on
est entré dans une période qui va durer
six mois
jusqu'à au mois d'avril a minima dont
les conditions climatiques sont
favorables à la circulation du virus
donc la première question avons nous une
chance pour qu'en février la situation
sanitaire nous permettent de baisser la
garde et de nous dire qu'on peut
sereinement se priver de la possibilité
d'activer lorsque le moment l'exigerait
des outils de gestion de crise sanitaire
la réponse elle est non et aucun expert
sérieux ne vous dira qu'on peut
considérer qu'en février la situation
sera différente de celle que nous
connaissons aujourd'hui et encore plus
en janvier pourquoi je vous parle de
janvier parce que si nous devions
revenir devant vous en mois de février
avec un nouveau texte de loi ce texte
serait évidemment présenté au cours du
mois de janvier au coeur de l'hiver qui
est le mois de la circulation virale par
excellence
elokobi n'échappe pas à la règle et nous
l'avons vu l'année dernière
est ce que pour autant
nous serons contraints d'activer tout ou
partie des outils
dont nous vous demandons la possibilité
de désactiver si la situation sanitaire
devait l'exiger là aussi la réponse est
non puisque ce que nous avons appris
avec la vaccination massive c'est que la
pression épidémique est sans doute
désormais moins importante en tant
qu'indicateur de suivi que la pression
sanitaires il ya une décorrélation entre
la pression épidémique et la pression
sanitaire la plus grande étude mondiale
sur l'impact de la vaccination et
française 11 millions de vaccinés 11
millions de vaccinés 92 % du risque
d'hospitalisation après 50 ans lorsqu'on
attaque siné ce qui veut dire que
autrefois on aurait eu trente mille cas
par jour dans le pays on savait qu'on
avait plusieurs milliers
d'hospitalisations à la clé et plusieurs
centaines de décès aujourd'hui grâce à
la vaccination on sait que si on
atteignait jeudi trente mille pourrait
dire 20000 40000 c'est pas une annonce
que je vous fais mais si on atteignait
30 mille cas par jour on n'aurait pas le
même impact d'ailleurs c'est ce qui
s'est passé pendant la quatrième vague
celle du variant delta on voit très bien
qu'il n'y a plus de corrélation entre le
nombre de contaminations et le nombre de
cas graves c'est tant mieux c'est la
vaccination qui nous protège
je le disais les conditions climatique
exacerbe d'environ 30% la circulation
des virus respiratoires ainsi qu'aux
vide et de l'autre côté nous estimons
que le pass sanitaires et les mesures de
jauger de gestion qui sont encore en
vigueur permettent de réduire d'environ
30% la circulation du virus est à dire
que sens des outils qui sont
actuellement en vigueur nous ne serions
pas à 5000 cas nous nous serions bien au
delà il suffit encore une fois pour en
avoir le coeur net de regarder du coup
tout re manche ce qui se passe en
angleterre il ya d'autres éléments
péjoratif qui peuvent intervenir dans la
période à venir il peut apparaître des
nouveaux variants
jusqu'ici il n'y avait pas de nouveaux
variants qu'ils soient en circulation
identifié aujourd'hui n'y a pas
formellement un nouveau variant mais il
ya un sous type de variants qu'on
connaît bien il ya le sous type du
variant delta s'appelle le à y pointent
4.2 y points 4 points 2 kits apparu
encore une fois en angleterre issu du
variant delta on connaît encore assez
peu de choses sur ce variant il
ressemble à s'y méprendre comme deux
gouttes d'eau aux variants delta mais
les premières études anglaises qui nous
remontent atteste d'une contagiosité
supérieur aux variants delta de l'ordre
de 10 à 15% ça vous paraît peut-être peu
mais sachez que ce sous type du variant
delta représente déjà 6 % des cas
positifs diagnostiqués en angleterre
c'est à dire qu'il a tendance à se
propager vite et que ce variant pourrait
provoquer un peu plus de circulation
virale que son que sont le frère dont il
est issu le variant delta est suivi
circulent en angleterre vous savez très
bien l'histoire se répète c'est qu'il
circule déjà probablement y rendre au
bref vous l'aurez compris dans les
prochains mois on a des raisons
d'espérer grâce à la vaccination massive
on a des raisons d'espérer grâce aux
outils de gestion de sanitaires dont
nous disposons notamment le pass et on a
des toutes les toutes les raisons de
rester extrêmement vigilant à part
l'apparition de sous types de variants
circulation exacerbée du coc vide
pendant la période hivernale et tout
cela je vous le dis va nous emmener un
minima de l'autre côté de l'hiver et
probablement pas avant le mois de mai
juin voire juillet c'est la raison pour
laquelle le gouvernement demande à la
représentation nationale de lui laisser
la possibilité si la situation
l'exigeait d'activer des outils déjà
éprouvée dont on sait qu'ils
fonctionnent et qui protège la
population le pass sanitaires pour part
éventuellement des mesures de gestion
plus lourdes telles que l'état d'urgence
localisé d'autre part
et donc nous vous demandons de pouvoir
poursuivre cela jusqu'à la date du 31
juillet c'est les députés ont eu
l'occasion de se prononcer sur cette
question et à majorité ont accordé la
confiance au gouvernement sur sur ce
point là il n'a je vous le dis ça
n'empêche pas ça n'empêche pas d'avoir
au contraire un moment d'échangé et de
débat et je viendrai très volontiers
devant vous au cours du mois de février
pour discuter de la situation sanitaire
et vous le savez
commission qu'à chaque fois vous m'avez
demandé c'est tout à fait normal de
venir devant vous je suis venu pour
pouvoir répondre à toutes les questions
qui pouvaient se poser et débattre voilà
l'objet je rentre pas plus dans les
détails j'ai compris qu'on avait peu de
temps mais je préférais faire une
introduction qui expliqué qu'ils
insistent sur la situation sanitaire
tu elle est à venir de manière à donner
la perspective et expliquer pourquoi
nous demandons de renouveler la
confiance dans la gestion de
l'utilisation de ces outils à dernier
mot pour dire que nous ne sommes pas là
dans une période extraordinaire de
prolongation des mesures puisque à deux
reprises je suis devenu vent venu devant
vous pour obtenir la confiance sur dix
mois sur 10 mois et demi alors que là
nous parlons d'une période de sept mois
et demi à 8 mois c'est à dire que la
période d'extension une prolongation et
de prorogation des mesures est plus
courte que lors de deux précédents
projets de loi qui portait sur le même
type de mesure jour merci merci monsieur
le ministre je propose qu'on nous
donnons la parole à nos deux rapporteurs
monsieur bah d'abord madame bruni
ensuite et puis après monsieur daumier
ce rassemblement et d'autres collègues
qui souhaitent s'inscrire on comprend
les notes précises pour tous les donc
monsieur questeur merci monsieur le
président monsieur le ministre je veux
d'abord vous remercier de votre
disponibilité personnelle puisque vous
avez répondu constamment nos invitations
pour l'échangé et de dialogue et c'est
évidemment très important face à une
crise telle que celle du co vide je veux
également remercier le gouvernement
d'avoir
respecté les prescriptions de la loi du
5 août en ce qui concerne son
information sur les effets économiques
et sanitaires
du nouvel outil que nous avons consentir
vous donnez qui était le pass sanitaires
possibles d'une audition n'est pas
d'ouvrir le débat entre nous mais de
vous poser des questions pour avoir plus
de précisions et éclairer les positions
que nous serons amenés à prendre d'abord
demain dès demain en commission des lois
et jeudi et dans la nuit de jeudi à
vendredi dans l'examen du texte que vous
nous avez proposé donc je m'en tiendrais
est strictement à quelques questions
j'ai observé dans les deux avis du
conseil scientifique du 5 et du 6
octobre que autant le conseil
scientifique estime qu il est absolument
certain qu'elle passe sanitaire a joué
un rôle déterminant
l'accélération des vaccinations autant
dit-il le rôle du pass sanitaire en tant
que mesures favorisant la protection des
avis des individus est plus difficile à
mettre en évidence
le pass sanitaire a été mis en place
début août alors que la décroissance de
l'épidémie du variant delta est plutôt
survenu vers le 20 juillet donc il a pu
contribuer dit le conseil scientifique à
cette décroissance mais il est difficile
de mesurer exactement dans quelle mesure
est-ce que vous avez des précisions à
nous apporter sur
l'utilité qu'a pu présenter le pass
sanitaires pour la prévention des
contaminations ça c'est ma première
question
deuxièmement on a pu observer
que si la viralité
du virus avec ces nouveaux variants n'a
cessé d'augmenter sa létalité n'a cessé
de diminuer et aujourd'hui on est quand
même dans une situation très différente
de celle au pluriel que nous avons pu
connaître jusqu'à présent pouvez-vous
nous nous préciser
quel rapport il y as entre le danger du
virus aujourd'hui et le danger qu'il a
pu avoir dès lors que les vaccinations
sont massives tout de même en france et
ça c'est un succès qu'il faut absolument
reconnaître et mettre en avant et dès
lors que les personnes contaminées sont
de plus en plus jeune et plus
résistantes au virus
autrement dit nous combattons avec les
mêmes armes une maladie qui n'est plus
la même et qui n'atteint plus les mêmes
personnes exactement je voudrais avoir
des précisions sur votre appréciation de
cette évolution de la situation par
ailleurs vous avez bien le relever et
c'est une source de préoccupation à
l'apparition de nouveaux variants le
rôle de l'hiver sur la propagation de
l'épidémie
ce qui se passe à l'est de l'europe et
ce qui se passe en grande-bretagne nous
sommes conscient de ceci mais il ya
aussi des éléments plus positifs il
apparaît de nouveau
moyen de traitement préventif ou curatif
est ce que vous pouvez nous faire un
point sur cette évolution
thème sud rapportaient
si elle la commission
de roche vous la commission des affaires
sociales la commission des lois nous
avons décidé cette audition commune de
monsieur verrons dans le cadre du texte
une vigilance sanitaire je crois que le
plus simple est immédiatement de lui
donner la parole mais ensuite on aura un
jeu de questions sachant que nous sommes
contraints dans le temps puisqu'il y à
ce matin les réunions groupe politique à
partir de 10h30 10h45 maximum voilà une
ministre et à vous merci d'être là merci
beaucoup monsieur président de la
commission des lois madame la présidente
de la commission des affaires sociales
monsieur le rapporteur
de la commission des lois madame la
rapporteure pour avis mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs ne sait pas donc
la première fois que je me présente
devant vous je crois que c'est la 11e
fois que je me présente devant vous dans
le cadre d'une d'une audition sur la
gestion de crise sanitaire
avec un projet de loi qui annonce la
couleur il s'agit plus d'état d'urgence
sanitaire mais bien de vigilance
sanitaire
et pour cause j'ai connu et pourquoi
j'ai connu des contextes où je me
présenter devant vous alors que les
hôpitaux se remplissait que les cas se
comptaient par dizaines de milliers et
que nous étions sur le point de mettre
en place de décréter où l'état d'urgence
localisé ou nationales ou des mesures de
confinement cette fois ci la situation
est différente et pour autant elle
impose cette vigilance sanitaire
que je viens plaidé devant vous devant
vous ce matin
la situation est différente parce
qu'effectivement nous sommes à 5000 cas
de circulation de virus par jour et qu'
il n'y a pas une charge hospitalière qui
soit aussi intense que celle que nous
avons connue et pour autant
avons-nous
devant nous des perspectives de
réductions d'épidémie voir d'écrasement
du virus la réponse est non en tout cas
ni à court ni à moyen terme j'en veux
pour preuve ce qui se passe en europe
vous savez sans doute toute l'europe est
soumise à une augmentation de la
pression épidémique en europe de l'est
là où la vaccination est bien plus
faible qu'en europe de l'ouest l'impact
sanitaire est ré elle est intense avec
des pays qui affichent des taux
d'incidence extrêmement élevé plus de
700 pour pour 100000 habitants sur sur
sept jours je pense à la roumanie
notamment la lettonie d'autres pays la
bulgarie la slovénie et en europe
occidentale
il ya le cas anglais avec une
vaccination qui est insuffisante de la
population l'arrêt de toute mesure vous
le savez de gestion de de la crise
décision qui a été prise au niveau
politique de faire comme si le virus
finalement n'engendrerait plus de dégâts
et la basse et du 45000 et bientôt du
cinquante mille cas par jour qui sont
enregistrés avec une charge hospitalière
qui commence quand même à poser des
questions d'ailleurs qui commence à être
soulevées au plus haut niveau de l'état
en angleterre vont-ils pouvoir célébrer
les fêtes de fin d'année ne vont-ils pas
devoir finalement mettre en place un
système de pass sanitaires il se pose la
question parce qu'il voit bien que la
croissance épidémique risque de ne pas
s'y arrêter et qui n'en maîtrisent plus
les tenants et aboutissants avec une
couverture vaccinale qui est plus faible
que chez nous nos voisins allemands
consiste souvent en exemple qui ont une
couverture vaccinale qui est plus faible
que chez nous ont dépassé les 13 14
mille cas certains jours ils sont en
phase de croissance épidémie qu'ils ont
un taux d'incidence qui est plus élevé
que le nôtre belgique pays bas tous les
pays qui nous entourent à l'exception
notable pour l'instant des pays du sud
de l'europe mais parce que de quoi
parlons nous nous parlons de conditions
climatiques plus humide est plus froide
qui sont propices à la circulation tous
les virus notamment les virus
respiratoires telles que la grippe lever
rs qui donne à bronchiolite bientôt la
gastro entérite que les français
connaissent bien et donc le coc vide et
nourrit je dirais est logé à la même
enseigne et donc dans l'europe du sud
les conditions climatiques sont encore
un peu plus favorable et un peu moins
propice et la circulation des virus mais
nul doute que l'espagne et l'italie ils
connaîtront prochainement une croissance
épidémies comme la nôtre puis dès qu'on
est entré dans une période qui va durer
six mois
jusqu'à au mois d'avril a minima dont
les conditions climatiques sont
favorables à la circulation du virus
donc la première question avons nous une
chance pour qu'en février la situation
sanitaire nous permettent de baisser la
garde et de nous dire qu'on peut
sereinement se priver de la possibilité
d'activer lorsque le moment n'exigerait
des outils de gestion de crise sanitaire
la réponse elle est non et aucun expert
sérieux ne vous dira qu'on peut
considérer qu'en février la situation
sera différente de celle que nous
connaissons aujourd'hui et encore plus
en janvier pourquoi je vous parle de
janvier parce que si nous devions
revenir devant vous au mois de février
avec un nouveau texte de loi ce texte
serait évidemment présenté au cours du
mois de janvier au coeur de l'hiver qui
est le mois de la circulation virale par
excellence locaux vides n'échappe pas à
la règle et nous l'avons vu l'année
dernière
est ce que pour autant nous serons
contraints d'activer tout ou partie des
outils
dont nous vous demandons la possibilité
de désactiver si la situation sanitaire
devait l'exiger là aussi la réponse est
non puisque ce que nous avons appris
avec la vaccination massive c'est que la
pression épidémique est sans doute
désormais moins importante en tant
qu'indicateur de suivi que la pression
sanitaires il ya une décorrélation entre
la pression épidémique la pression
sanitaire la plus grande étude mondiale
sur l'impact de la vaccination et
française 11 millions de vaccinés 11
millions de non vaccinés 92 % du risque
d'hospitalisation après 50 ans lorsqu on
est vaccinés ce qui veut dire que
autrefois on aurait eu trente mille cas
par jour dans le pays on savait qu'on
avait plusieurs milliers
d'hospitalisations à la clé et plusieurs
centaines de décès aujourd'hui grâce à
la vaccination on sait que si on
atteignait jeudi 30 me je pourrais dire
20000 40000 c'est pas une annonce que je
vous fais mais si on atteignait 30 mille
cas par jour on n'aurait pas le même
impact d'ailleurs c'est ce qui s'est
passé pendant la quatrième vague celle
du variant delta on voit très bien qu'il
n'y a plus de corrélation entre le
nombre de contaminations et le nombre de
cas graves c'est tant mieux c'est la
vaccination qui nous protège
je le disais les conditions climatique
exacerbe d'environ 30% la circulation
des virus respiratoires ainsi que le co
vide et de l'autre côté nous estimons
que le pass sanitaires et les mesures de
jauger de gestion qui sont encore en
vigueur permettent de réduire d'environ
30% la circulation du virus est à dire
que sans les outils qui sont
actuellement en vigueur nous ne serions
pas à 5000 cas nous aurions bien au delà
il suffit encore une fois pour en avoir
le coeur net de regarder du coup outre
manche ce qui se passe en angleterre il
ya d'autres éléments péjoratif qui
peuvent intervenir dans la période à
venir il peut apparaître des nouveaux
variants
jusqu'ici il n'y avait pas de nouveaux
variants qui soit en circulation ou
identifié aujourd'hui n'y a pas
formellement un nouveau variant mais il
ya un sous type de variants qu'on
connaît bien il a le soutien du variant
delta s'appelle le à y points 4 points 2
e y points 4 points 2 kits apparu encore
une fois en angleterre issu du variant
delta on connaît encore assez peu de
choses sur ce variant il ressemble à s'y
méprendre comme deux gouttes d'eau aux
variants delta mais les premières études
anglaises qui nous remontent atteste
d'une contagiosité supérieur aux
variants delta de l'ordre de 10 à 15% ça
vous paraît peut-être peu mais sachez
que ce sous type du variant delta
représente déjà 6 % des cas positifs
diagnostiqués en angleterre c'est à dire
qu'il a tendance à se propager vite et
que ce variant pourrait provoquer un peu
plus de circulation virale que son que
sont le frère dont il est issu le
variant delta et circulent en angleterre
vous savez très bien l'histoire se
répète c'est qu'il circule déjà
probablement alejandro bref vous l'aurez
compris dans les prochains mois on a des
raisons d'espérer grâce à la vaccination
massive on a des raisons d'espérer grâce
aux outils de gestion de sanitaires dont
nous disposons notamment le pass et on a
des toutes les toutes les raisons de
rester extrêmement vigilant à part
l'apparition de sous types de variants
circulation exacerbée du coc vide
pendant la période hivernale et tout
cela je vous le dis va nous emmener à
minima de l'autre côté de l'hiver et
probablement pas avant le mois de mai
juin voire juliet c'est la raison pour
laquelle le gouvernement demande à la
représentation nationale de lui laisser
la possibilité si la situation
l'exigeait d'activer des outils déjà
éprouvée dont on sait qu'ils
fonctionnent et qui protège la
population le pass sanitaires pour part
éventuellement des mesures de gestion
plus lourdes telles que l'état d'urgence
localisé d'autre part
et donc nous vous demandons de pouvoir
poursuivre cela jusqu'à la date du 31
juillet c'est les députés ont eu
l'occasion de se prononcer sur cette
question et à majorité ont accordé la
confiance au gouvernement sur ce point
là il n'a je vous le dis ça n'empêche
pas ça n'empêche pas d'avoir au
contraire un moment d'échangé et de
débat et je viendrai très volontiers
devant vous au cours du mois de février
pour discuter de la situation en italie
terre et vous le savez
commission qu'à chaque fois vous m'avez
demandé c'est tout à fait normal de
venir devant vous je suis venu pour
pouvoir répondre à toutes les questions
qui pouvaient se poser et débattre voilà
l'objet je rentre pas plus dans les
détails j'ai compris qu'on avait peu de
temps mais je préférais faire une
introduction qui expliqué qu'ils
insistent sur la situation sanitaire
actuelle et à venir de manière à donner
la perspective et expliquer pourquoi
nous demandons de renouveler la
confiance dans la gestion de
l'utilisation de ces outils un dernier
mot pour dire que nous ne sommes pas là
dans une période extraordinaire de
prolongation des mesures puisque à deux
reprises je suis devenu vent venu devant
vous pour obtenir la confiance sur dix
mois sur 10 mois et demi alors que là
nous parlons d'une période de sept mois
et demi à 8 mois c'est d'être la perte
d'extension une prolongation et de
prorogation des mesures est plus courte
que lors de deux précédents projets de
loi qui portait sur le même type de
mesure je vous remercie merci monsieur
le ministre je propose qu'on nous
donnons la parole à nos deux rapporteurs
monsieur bah d'abord madame bruni
ensuite et puis après monsieur juillet
rassemblement et puis d'autres collègues
qui souhaitent s'inscrire on prend les
notes précises pour tous les donc
monsieur questeur merci monsieur le
président monsieur mise je veux d'abord
vous remercier de votre disponibilité
personnelle puisque vous avez répondu
constamment nos invitations pour
l'échangé et de dialogue et c'est
évidemment très important face à une
crise telle que celle du co vide je veux
également remercier le gouvernement
d'avoir
respecté les prescriptions de la loi du
5 août en ce qui concerne son
information sur les effets économiques
et sanitaires
d'une nouvelle boutique
nous avons consenti à vous donner qui
était le pass sanitaires
possibles d'une audition n'est pas
d'ouvrir le débat entre nous mais de
vous poser des questions pour avoir plus
de précisions et éclairer les positions
que nous serons amenés à prendre d'abord
demain dès demain en commission des lois
et jeudi et dans la nuit de jeudi à
vendredi dans l'examen du texte que vous
nous avez proposé donc je m'en tiendrais
est strictement à quelques questions
j'ai observé dans les deux avis du
conseil scientifique du 5 et du 6
octobre que autant le conseil
scientifique estime qu il est absolument
certain qu'elle passe sanitaire a joué
un rôle déterminant pour l'accélération
des vaccinations autant dit-il le rôle
du passani terre en tant que mesures
favorisant la protection d un vide des
individus est plus difficile à mettre en
évidence
le pass sanitaire a été mis en place
début août alors que la décroissance de
l'épidémie du variant delta est plutôt
survenu vers le 20 juillet donc il a pu
contribuer deal conseil scientifique à
cette décroissance mais il est difficile
de mesurer exactement dans quelle mesure
est-ce que vous avez des précisions à
nous apporter sur
l'utilité qu'a pu présenter le pass
sanitaires pour la prévention des
contaminations ça c'est ma première
question
deuxièmement on a pu observer que si la
viralité
du virus avec ces nouveaux variants n'a
cessé d'augmenter sa létalité n'a cessé
de diminuer et aujourd'hui on est quand
même dans une situation très différente
de celle au pluriel que nous avons pu
connaître jusqu'à présent pouvez-vous
nous nous préciser
quel rapport il y as entre le danger du
virus aujourd'hui et le danger qu'il a
pu avoir dès lors que les vaccinations
sont massives tout de même en france et
ça c'est un succès qu'il faut absolument
reconnaître et mettre en avant et dès
lors que les personnes contaminées sont
de plus en plus jeune et plus distante
au virus autrement dit nous combattons
avec les mêmes armes une maladie qui
n'est plus la même et qui n'atteint plus
les mêmes personnes exactement je
voudrais avoir des précisions sur votre
appréciation de cette évolution de la
situation par ailleurs vous avez bien le
relever et c'est une source de
préoccupation l'apparition de nouveaux
variants le rôle de l'hiver sur la
propagation de l'épidémie
ce qui se passe à l'est de l'europe et
ce qui se passe en grande-bretagne nous
sommes conscient de ceci mais il ya
aussi des éléments plus positifs
il apparaît de nouveau
moyen de traitement préventif ou curatif
est ce que vous pouvez nous faire un
point sur cette évolution et sur
l'anticipation qu'on peut avoir de la
mise à disposition des prescripteurs et
des patients de ces nouveaux produits
nouveaux médicaments enfin se pose la
question
de la poursuite de la vaccination est ce
que vous considérez que nous avons
atteint
ou plutôt pour être plus nuancé nous ne
sommes pas loin d'avoir atteint un
plafond dans les vaccinations
et ou au contraire est-ce qu'on peut
encore espérer gagner quelques marges je
vois que les personnes âgées de plus de
80 ans en france sont
14% à ne pas être encore vaccinés tandis
que dans certains pays voisins il n'y a
que 5 % des plus de 80 ans qui ne sont
pas vaccinés que peut-on faire pour
augmenter le taux de vaccination des
personnes ayant atteint leur grand âge
est ce que la courbe actuelle dont on
sent pour la première vaccination
qu'elle se ralentit la première
vaccination est un bon indicateur
parce que laissent anticiper la seconde
est ce que le gouvernement à envisager
de nouveaux moyens d'action de
communication pour faire redémarrer
le
la courbe des vaccinations alors qu'on
voit que
c'est de plus en plus difficile parce
qu'on est aux marges et et autres
questions sur la vaccination la
troisième dose est ce que le
gouvernement entend
recommander la généralisation de la
troisième dose compte tenu du fait que
la vaccination est de plus en plus enfin
plutôt les fêtes du vaccin dans le temps
diminue si monsieur chris turner vice
présidente gruny
merci monsieur président même la
présidente monsieur monsieur le ministre
un merci d'être d'être ici présent nous
avons toujours plaisir à vous à vous
entendre ici et dans l'hémicycle est
également donc merci pour ce matin être
à nos côtés juste avant de passer aux
questions plus générales
je voulais vous demander si les masques
et le gel était encore nécessaire utile
parce que on voit bien que de plus en
plus en fait les personnes les enlèvent
ou veulent les enlever et ce serait bien
de faire un petit rappel et de comment
on place le masque notamment sur le nez
vous et de vous aimeriez beaucoup la
présidente gruny merci alors j'ai quatre
questions alors tout d'abord
l'obligation vaccinale don qui est une
obligation légale qui a vocation depuis
le 15 octobre à s'appliquent à
l'ensemble des personnes concernées et
ce sur tout le territoire national régie
par le droit commun pourtant force est
constater que certains territoires je
pense ici aux outre mer particulièrement
aux antilles guyane montrent des taux de
vaccination des soignants
particulièrement en établissement de
santé ou médico sociaux particulièrement
bas vous avez indiqué dans vos récentes
déclarations que la loi devait
s'appliquer partout mais vous montrer
avec votre collègue ministre d outre-mer
une certaine tolérance sur la situation
de ces territoires n'est-il pas
paradoxal d'avoir une souplesse
d'application dans les territoires
dernièrement dans une situation si
critiques qu'elle a nécessité nécessité
le retour à l'état d'urgence comment
conciliez-vous l'impératif de continuité
des soins et le respect de la loi je
rappelle qu'ici au sénat nous avions
rejetée par exemple un amendement qui
visait à permettre de suspendre
l'obligation en cas de besoin de
services que nous estimions de nature à
d inciter au respect de la vaccination
ensuite les recommandations de la haute
autorité de santé concernant l'évolution
du schéma vaccinal ont notamment conduit
le gouvernement à proposer aux soignants
une dose de rappel comptez-vous dans les
mois à venir adapter le schéma de
vaccination obligatoire et rendre
nécessaire voire obligatoire la
troisième dose je souligne d'ailleurs
que la commission des affaires sociales
avait choisi de dissocier le schéma
vaccinal nécessaires au passage terre de
ce livre permettant de satisfaire à
l'obligation vaccinale
justement en vue d'anticiper la
possibilité de telles évolutions
troisième question si je souhaiterais
vous interroger sur les modifications
que vous apportez à l'article 13 de la
loi du 5 août concernant les modalités
de contrôle du respect de l'obligation
vaccinale
vous revendiquez à cet article une
dérogation très générales au secret
médical sans viser précisément ni dans
l'étude d'impact ni encore moins dans le
dispositif et personnes qui pourraient
être amenées comment l'anticipent à
accéder aux fichiers ces vaccins quelle
conception avez-vous de la protection du
secret médical quand il concerne
l'épidémie de kovy 19 nous voulons que
le dispositif fonctionne mais la
simplicité opérationnelle ne justifie
pas tout si une dérogation peut
s'entendre pour les personnes soumises à
l'obligation vaccinale
comment pouvons-nous ensemble mieux la
définir et ne pas laisser penser que par
ce biais et si vaccin devient une base
de données médicales en accès beaucoup
trop ouvert
sur les questions de droit du travail
le texte contient plusieurs habilitation
à légiférer par ordonnances qui sont
formulées de manière trop large ou dans
les objectifs ne sont pas suffisamment
précis en particulier quelle adaptation
supplémentaire de niveau législatif
pourrait-il être nécessaire de prévoir
sur le complément employeurs aux
indemnités journalières maladie alors
qu'un régime d'exception est inscrit de
manière pérenne dans le code du travail
et permet déjà aux gouvernements de
déroger par décret aux conditions de
versement de cette indemnité
complémentaire en cas de crise sanitaire
sur l'activité partielle de longue durée
ne vous paraît-il impossible d'écrire
une disposition en dur dans le projet de
loi plutôt que demander une habilitation
vous savez qu'ici au sénat nous n'aimons
pas beaucoup les ordonnances
et nu
qui revient de votre mère
où la situer où la situation est
particulièrement grave merci madame la
présidente merci monsieur le ministre
bon en complément parce que mes philippe
bas et pascale gruny ont posé je tirais
l'essentiel des questions mais moi
monsieur le ministre voudrait que vous
nous expliquiez au fond quel est
l'intérêt du pass annie terre sur une
population qui est vaccinée à un niveau
très élevé il y avait il y avait deux
objectifs as pas de sanitaires que j'en
appelle nous avons
la première fois approuvé un
pouce et à la vaccination
une obligation vaccinale déguisé bon on
aurait pu avoir une obligation vaccinale
franches mais passons une obligation
vaccinale déguisés qui a marché qui a
très bien fonctionné tout le monde
connaît les chiffres du nombre de
français qui se sont vaccinés et
deuxièmement on pouvait espérer parce
qu'on avait pas de données à 6 avec
l'expérience qu'ils pouvaient nous le
dire une réduction de la circulation
virale or sur cet aspect là le pass
sanitaire n'a pas démontré
d'efficacité très nette ça a été rappelé
par le conseil scientifique vient d'être
appelé par le rapporteur vous avancez
une donnée de 30 % de la circulation
mais j'ai cru comprendre dans vos propos
vous y vous anglo biais les gestes
barrière dans cette donnée là en tout
état de cause c'est un effet qui est qui
est faible sur la réduction de la
circulation virale ce n'est pas un motif
de satisfaction c'est un constat et donc
quel est l'objectif de maintien du pass
sanitaires sur une population très
vacciner vous nous avez dit on ne peut
pas viser d'écrasement du virus mais je
ne sais pas ce qu'est cette notion
exactement d'écrasement il ya soit notre
pays cherchent une stratégie zéro
coville ce que personne ne propose voilà
ça paraît tout à fait hors de portée
soit on vise et je voudrais savoir si
c'est votre stratégie de ramener le
virus un bruit de fond avec des petites
récurrence climatique ou autres voilà et
un bruit de fond un virus qui provoque
un bruit de fond avec des récurrences
c'est absorbable le système de santé
premièrement et deuxièmement ça ne
nécessite aucune mesure exorbitant du
droit commun donc si
voilà si si c'est bien ça la stratégie
on a du mal à comprendre ce que vous
attendez de la prolongation du pas de
sanitaires d'autant que
sur les mesures en ce qui concerne
incitation à la vaccination la dernière
mesure dont vous espériez un effet la
fin de la gratuité totale des tests pas
la fin du remboursement mais la fin la
gratuité totale il semblerait que à j +
11 n'est pas produit d'effet mais vous
nous direz si vous voyez une reprise
nette de la vaccination depuis la fin de
cette gratuité totale de voilà donc la
question vraiment c'est pour vous quel
niveau d'épidémie légitime cette
restriction que c'est une restriction
liberté le pass sanitaires et pour
quelle efficacité
merci madame la présidente monsieur
présent sur le ministre
trois observations et question d'abord
monsieur mines dans votre tour d'europe
vous avez passé rapidement sur l'espagne
qui pourtant malgré l'absence de passé
l'état dans ce pays a un taux de
vaccination supérieur à la france et a
priori une contamination inférieur
deuxième
deuxième intervention
depuis que les tests sont rendus payants
quelques ailes
payant ou non remboursés quel que
constatez-vous sur
la défilent à l'appréciation du taux
d'incidence sur la baisse du nombre de
tests effectués donc par ce qui pourrait
entraîner la baisse du nombre de tests
positifs et si on les ramène à un
chiffre de cent mille habitants on
pourrait imaginer que ce chiffre baisse
artificiellement du fait que moins de
tests sont pratiqués
troisième et dernière d'animaux
la cnil de manière de manière régulière
dénonce le risque d'accoutumance au
passé ni terre ce risque d'accoutumance
nous le constatons tout le monde a dit
que le pass était temporaire force est
de constater qu'il s'installe dans nos
vies quotidiennes comme un élément
courant et je veux bien que j'en sois un
un pourfendeur beaucoup de français se
le sont appropriés et revendique cette
appropriation du genre mais finalement
ça ne nous gêne pas moi avec mon mât
lecture
demande de la cnil depuis sept ans je
peux vous assurer que c'est exactement
ce que nous craignons et donc qu'est ce
que vous entendez faire pour qu'on lutte
contre la coutume ans au contrôle social
sur la base d'éléments de santé
monsieur le ministre ensuite nous aurons
deux autres question monsieur le
ministre
d'abord je voulais remercier les
sénatrices et sénateurs qui se sont
exprimés qui
pour la qualité du dialogue que nous
pouvons avoir à mon tour je suis pas sûr
de dans mon rôle mais je voulais vous
remercier parce que je me souviens du
dernier texte que nous avons eues adopté
effet j'ai le rapporteur bas s'en
souvient aussi bien que moi des
conditions dans lesquelles il vous a été
demandé de l'adopter de l'urgence qu'il
y avait à l'impérieuse l'impérieuse
nécessité qu'il y avait trouvé un accord
et le sénat était en responsabilité
présent et je tenais à le souligner
et je me réjouis à nouveau de pouvoir
débattre et discuter avec vous et la
qualité des questions montrent que vous
avez une connaissance extrêmement fine
et un suivi très très rapprochées toutes
ces questions est ce qu'on peut
quantifier l'impact du du pass
sanitaires sur la circulation du virus
moi je vais vous poser une autre
question
est ce qu'on peut quantifier l'impact du
masque dans la pile dans l'épidémie
est-ce qu'on peut quantifier l'impact du
gel hydroalcoolique ça répond aussi une
question qu'on m'a posée manama
sénatrice gruny dans l'épidémie il est
difficile d'approché à la contamination
près quel est l'impact de ces différents
outils pour autant vous savez qu'à la
théorie et yann empirique et l'empirique
c'est-à-dire l'observer nous permettent
d'attester que certains outils sont
fonctionnels efficace voire
indispensable dans la période épidémique
pandémique que nous connaissons avec le
co vide
certaines approximations j'en ai parlé
de salaire dans l' intervention
liminaire montre que le patient aurait
pu permettre de réduire de 25 à 30% des
contaminations parce qu'ils protègent
des établissements qu'ils ont des lieux
très propice à la création de clusters
camp vise identifié que vous gardez en
pleine vague épidémique des restaurants
ouverts et que vous avez une chute
drastique du nombre de clusters et donc
d'extension de contamination issus de
clusters dans des restaurants alors que
les restaurants ont pu rester ouverts
qu'est-ce qui est qu'elle a été la
différence était pas sanitaires donc
c'est ainsi que vous arrivez approximer
avoisiner l'impact d'une mesure et 7
mesure passe est quelque chose qui est
posible par ailleurs vous l'avez
souligné à juste titre monsieur le
sénateur bas vous avez dit quand on a
1000 passes on était déjà en diminution
et c'est à vous ferai remarquer vous
pourrez regarder c'est assez intéressant
et en même temps assez compréhensible à
chaque fois qu'on a mis en place des
mesures de gestion y compris d'ailleurs
des mesures de confinement au moment où
ces mesures se mettait en place il y
avait avant même qu'on puisse en mesurer
la pleine efficacité avait une petite
réduction pourquoi parce que vous avez
une adaptation des comportements et que
quand vous sonnez l'alertent on vous
fait qu'on appelle en affreux
anglicismes un wake up call pour dire
attention la situation est grave on va
devoir agir vous avez immédiatement une
adaptation des comportements de la même
manière quand vous êtes dans une
épidémie qui vivotent et qui fait moins
parler d'elle vous avez une traitance au
relâchement relâchement sans doute du
contrôle de passe dans certains endroits
de samrée de et de son respect
relâchement des gestes barrières madame
la sénatrice raison pour laquelle nous
avons lancé une nouvelle campagne de
communication nationale pour rappeler
l'importance des gestes barrières du
port du masque du gel hydroalcoolique de
la distanciation sociale pour des
fictions des situations les plus à
risque et donc ces questions
comportementales sont à prendre en
compte vous avez posé des questions sur
les risques du virus chez les personnes
vaccinées d'abord à chaque fois qu'on a
eu un nouveau variant est le delta n'a
pas fait exception à la règle il ya eu
une pathogénicité donc une dangerosité
intrinsèque au virus un peu plus
importante dire que là mais le virus
quand ils varient devient un peu plus
dangereux et peut créer statistiquement
plus de cas graves
quand on est vaccinés on est protégé à
plus de 90% compter cas grave c'est très
bien mais c'est pas du 100 % vous avez
des gens qui bien que vacciner même si
c'est beaucoup plus rare peuvent
présenter des situations des cas graves
or plus le virus circule
plus vous allez avoir de risque d'être
contaminé que vous soyez vacciner ou non
même si la protection conférée par la
vaccination est réelle et forte vous
avez aussi des gens qui peuvent être
vaccinés mais immunodéprimés et donc une
fragilité d'un système immunitaire qui
peut les exposer à des risques de forme
grave vous avez des gens qui sont très
fragiles très âgées raison pour laquelle
nous faisons les rappels de vaccination
qui bien que vacciner peuvent être
exposés à des risques de formes graves
et vous avez des gens qui peuvent faire
des coville l'on manque encore d'études
on manque encore d'études suffisamment
fine sur la possibilité de présenter des
séquelles à distance même quand on n'a
pas eu une forme grave mais qu'on ait eu
un peu vite symptomatique conçoit
vacciner ou non donc on reste dans une
logique de prudence qui est tout à fait
compris poser la question des
traitements il ya encore un affreux
gamin affreux anglicismes c'est ce qu'on
appelle un game 'changer
c'est le mot le mipih ravir le menu pire
aviaire est une molécule anti viral qui
est commercialisée désormais ou presque
et qui a montré que lorsqu'elle était
prise de façon précoce chez des gens qui
sont symptomatiques et c'est un
traitement oral cette fois ci par une
injection sur sept jours à en comprimés
et bien ils pouvaient réduire de l'ordre
de 50% le risque de formes graves
imaginez que nous ayons eu à la place de
traitements non fonctionnel mais
certains distribué comme on distribuait
des bonbons haribo hélas imaginez que
nous ayons à l'époque un traitement
antiviral qui réduisait de 50% le nombre
de cas graves imaginez l'impact
sanitaire dans notre pays au cours de la
1ère et la 2ème vague on aurait eu
beaucoup moins de décès est beaucoup
moins de cas graves la science parfois
prend un peu plus de temps que ce qu'on
souhaiterait mais la science a permis
d'identifier des premiers traitements
probant démontré dans les landes et dans
des études cliniques vérifier relu par
des comités internationaux et ce
traitement le menu pire à dire la france
en a commandé s'est positionné très tôt
en précommande qui j'ai confirmé des
commandes cinquante mille doses de ce
médicament vont être livrés à la france
a compté des derniers jours de novembre
des premiers jours de décembre c'est à
dire dès que les traitements sortiront
des chaînes de production nous aurons
également dans les semaines qui suivront
dans les mois qui suivront de nouveau
traitement par anticorps monoclonaux
vous savez que la france on dispose
aujourd'hui mais c'est traitement par
anticorps monoclonaux se renforce encore
deviennent de plus en plus efficaces et
le cocktail des deux j'ai des gens qui
sont à risque de faire de formes graves
pourraient réduire très fortement le
risque de faire des cas graves qui
serait forcément une très bonne nouvelle
puisque vaccination plus traitement
antiviral plus anticorps monoclonaux
égale impacts sanitaires bien moindre et
ça nous mettrait aussi entre guillemets
à l'abri de l'est en cas de vague
épidémique lit un nouveau variant dont
on ignore encore les dégâts qui
pourraient provoquer dans notre pays je
vais poser la question du plafond de
vaccination est ce qui nous reste encore
des gens qui ne sont pas vaccinés qu'on
pourraient vacciner nous on part du
principe que 92% de la population
vaccinable devrait pouvoir être vacciné
c'est je dirais le le la campagne idéal
de vaccination à l'échelle de la
population c'est en toute façon on est
déjà en dehors de tous les records je
vous rappelle qu'on est bien au delà de
ce que les enquêtes d'opinion ont montré
comme intention vaccinale dans le pays
et donc ça veut dire qu'il nous reste
encore environ deux millions de
personnes dont on se dit d'après les
études qualitatives qui sont faites par
les sondages et ce sont des gens qui
attendent et qui ne sont pas opposés à
l'idée de se faire vacciner et donc ces
deux millions de personnes là nous
allons les chercher par tout médecin
pharmacien vous savez que les libéraux
peuvent désormais commander autant de
freezer qu'ils veulent et faire des
injections autant qu'ils le veulent que
les pharmaciens sont fondés à préparer
des seringues monodoses pour que les
médecins puissent avoir une seringue
monodoses dans leur cabinet pour
vacciner à l'emporte-pièce un patient
qui viendraient qui ne seraient pas
encore vaccinés qui tirent et pourquoi
pas les infirmiers l'échidné les sacha
tout le monde vaccine on a lancé des
campagnes une instruction
interministérielle est parti encore
récemment pour mobiliser tous les
acteurs de terrain réorienter certaines
lignes de vaccination de centres de
vaccination pour faire du aller vers en
ruralité dans les quartiers populaires
des villes là où il ya encore des gens
qu'on peut vacciner on est à plus de 51
millions on sera je l'espère à 52
millions de primo vaccination peut être
en décembre jeu qu'on voit monsieur le
sénateur chez plume a posé la question
mais on voit que la fin de la gratuité
complète des tests s'est accompagnée
d'un petit rebond de primo vaccination
on est remonté de laure de 40000 à 50000
primo vaccination par jour ça compte
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs ça
compte parce que cinquante mille par
jour ça nous fait du 300 milles par
semaine ça veut dire quant à moi c'est
un million de français qui n'étaient pas
vaccinés qui le sont donc si on continue
sur ce rythme c'est important parce que
un million de vaccinés qui sont
vaccinées c'est un impact sanitaire qui
est petit est épargné et c'est un risque
de mesures de gestion ou de confinement
qui s'éloigne encore davantage
l'enjeu des rappels il est majeur
il faut que les personnes âgées que les
personnes avec des maladies chroniques
ou les personnes qui ont eu une seule
dose de jones elles puissent et les
soignants puisse avoir cette dose de
rappel les statistiques ne sont pas
excellentes mais elles ne sont pas non
plus mauvaises si je prends la situation
des plus de 65 ans et qu'on regarde six
mois après la dernière dose on est à 55
% qui ont déjà reçu leur appel et quand
on regarde un mois plus tard à sept mois
on l'aide à des statistiques j'ai pas
encore les derniers chiffres pas vous
les donner mais
et on sait déjà que c'est nettement
supérieur cela dit il faut qu'on aille
davantage proposé de rappel aux
personnes quand windows de john seine et
aux personnes qui sont atteintes de
comorbidité vous avez posé la question
de l'intégration potentielle dans le
pass des doses de rappel pour les
publics les plus fragiles
ça fait l'objet de réflexions et ça fait
l'objet désormais d'une saisine des
autorités sanitaires compétentes c'est à
dire le comité d'orientation des
stratégies vaccinales la haute autorité
de santé et le conseil scientifique est
ce qu'il ya lieu ou non de demander pour
conserver le bénéfice de son passe
lorsqu'on est particulièrement fragile
d'attester du fait d'avoir reçu la dose
de rappel je n'ai pas la réponse mais
j'ai posé la question pour la sénatrice
grünig m'avait aussi posé la question de
l'obligation vaccinale en territoires
ultramarins c'est une situation
éminemment complexe une vague épidémique
sans précédent des dégâts spitalier
majeur 2500 soignants depuis la mi-août
qui ont quitté la métropole pour aller
prêter main forte à leurs collègues en
outre m dans des conditions parfois
difficiles y compris des conditions
d'accueil qui peuvent être parfois
difficile beaucoup de choses
d'informations circulent beaucoup de
peurs non fondées alors que la peur
fondée elle c'est la peur du virus et de
la vague épidémique une protection de la
population qui n'est pas suffisante et
les protections des soignants qui n'est
pas suffisante ce que j'ai demandé c'est
que la loi s'applique et je le redis la
loi de la république doit s'appliquer
sur tout le territoire la république il
en va aussi de la crédibilité de la
parole de l'état on tient compte madame
la sénatrice tout de même de la réalité
sanitaire
delà de jeudi raid la charge de travail
qui repose aujourd'hui sur les
directeurs d'hôpitaux et sur les équipes
médicales et soignantes et j'ai demandé
à ce que la loi s'applique mais qu'elle
s'applique avec je dirais le bon
jugement et je préfère qu au lieu de
travailler à l'échelle de tout
l'établissement du jour au lendemain on
aille équipe par équipe unité par unité
service par service convaincre les
derniers réticents et prendre des
mesures de suspension là où c'est
nécessaire j'ai annoncé une médiation
qui va pouvoir partir et qui va aller
sur place en martinique pour établir les
conditions d'un dialogue serein avec
l'ensemble des parties prenantes pour
que la loi s'applique dans de bonnes
conditions et surtout qu'on fasse
progresser la vaccination par ailleurs
j'ai une donnée intéressante n'était pas
encore sortie pour vous qu une question
qui m'a été posée plusieurs fois
qu'advient-il des soignants en métropole
ou en outre-mer qui aurait été
suspendues faute d'être vacciné et bien
des premières remontées dont je dispose
les deux tiers d'entre eux les deux
tiers des soignants suspendus sont
revenus au travail une fois vacciner les
deux tiers c'est bien c'est bien on est
donc un taux de couverture vaccinale des
salariés des établissements sanitaires
et médico sociaux qui est extrêmement
élevé et un taux de suspension et de
démission qui est extrêmement faible
c'est donc je le dis et vous avez été en
responsabilité vous avez accompagné
l'obligation vaccinale des soignants
c'était une obligation qui s'applique
dans de bonnes conditions sur le
territoire national
sur la question de la dérogation au
secret médical et de l'ess et de l'accès
au logiciel est si vague le principe
posé c'est que l'établissement chargé du
contrôle peut connaître le statut
vaccinal de l'agent s'agissant des
établissements de santé et le cadre sera
précédée par un décret en conseil d'état
après avis de la cnil donc ne vous
inquiétez pas il n'y a pas de on n'a pas
du tout l'intention de donner accès à et
sivac à qui que ce soit ça passera
toujours par un intermédiaire et
uniquement pour permettre aux gens qui
doivent faire respecter une obligation
on a fait respecter dans de bonnes
conditions
une dérogation par exemple ont laissé
chez les soignants qu'on connaît depuis
des années des années sur l'hépatite b
sur la diphtérie tétanos la pl la polio
est une obligation de pouvoir contrôler
le respect de l'obligation vaccinale par
les employeurs donc on est dans quelque
chose qui hors droit commun mais qui
aident mais qui existent déjà dans le
droit est utilisé depuis des décennies
dans notre de notre pays sur le droit du
travail j'ai bien entendu votre votre
objection sur l e et le b mal que vous
mettez sur leur donne ans
néanmoins sachez qu'il s'agit uniquement
de dispositions favorables salariés
uniquement dispositions favorables aux
salariés pour éviter des suspensions ou
dj ou de salaire dans des conditions qui
nécessiterait la fermeture d'entreprises
où le recours au chômage partiel et donc
le gouvernement fait le choix de la
réactivité de la flexibilité de manière
à pouvoir décider au jour le jour s'il
était besoin de mesures permettant la
conservation des droits pour les
salariés ce ne sont en aucun cas des
mesures qui rognerait sur leurs droits
or si on était dans un mécanisme
classique il faudrait alors concertés
l'ensemble des parties prenantes ce qui
ferait perdre un mois et je crois que
les français depuis début de la crise
sanitaire nous son gré de leur avoir
permis de percevoir sans délai les
revenus qui leur étaient dues et ne pas
avoir de suspension de revenus parce que
là ce serait évidemment une catastrophe
pour eux quel est l'objectif du pass
thani terre quand tout le monde est
vaccinée
c'est une très bonne question que pose
le sénateur juillet
quels objectifs dans mes 6 ans pour cent
des gens sont vaccinés le passe à
lithaire n'a plus de sens puisque par
définition tout le monde est là vous
avez encore vous avez encore 10% de la
population vaccinable qui n'est pas
vacciné et donc vous avez encore 10% des
gens qui n'ont pas le pass imaginez un
établi imaginer une circulation du virus
mettons qu'on soit à vingt ou trente
mille cas par jour dans le pays d'accord
imaginez que vous ayez un établissement
recevant du public qui réunit 300
personnes qui n'ont qui parce qu'ils
sont pas sanitaire n'engendre plus le
port systématique du masque
statistiquement vous aurez une chance
sur je peux vous faire un calcul comme
ça mais imaginons une chance sur x que
quelqu'un de non vaccinés contagieux
soient présents dans les établissements
recevant du public et donc
statistiquement un risque de
contamination d'autres personnes autour
qui peuvent créer des chaînes de
contamination donc c'est ceinture et
bretelles je voudrais vous faire une
métaphore monsieur le député monsieur le
sénateur pardonnez moi imaginez vous
ayez des voitures automatiques qui soit
dont on nous disent qu'elles sont
parfaitement sûre et qu'elles ne
provoquent plus d' accidents de la route
est ce que pour autant de les premiers
mois vous avez retiré la ceinture vous
allez à conserver en vous disant lusage
nous dira lusage nous dira si le fait
que ces pilote automatique soit
sécurisée nous permettent de retirer le
port de la ceinture obligatoire bah on
est dans cette logique là on n'a pas
suffisamment de recul à ce stade pour
pouvoir nous priver d'un outil qui est
fonctionnel qui est bien acceptée par
les gens qui est très bien accepté par
les gens avec le recul monsieur le
sénateur bassi est très bien accepté par
les gens aujourd'hui je les enquêtes
d'opinion montrent que les français sont
favorables aux pass sanitaire dans leur
majorité parce qu'ils ont compris ça les
protéger et que sa note sur sa marge en
dre pas de réaction eu droit ce qui ne
veut pas dire qu'on veut le maintenir
dans la durée ça veut pas dire qu'on
veut maintenir le pas dans la durée
c'est pas un outil avec lequel nous
allons vivre pendant des années mais ça
veut dire que dans la situation dans la
situation pandémique que nous
connaissons les français ont compris que
le pack solitaire avait permis de ne pas
fermer les bars de ne pas fermer les
restaurants de ta ferme et les théâtres
de ne pas fermer les cinémas que nous
avons connu une meilleure saison
touristique en 2021 qu'en 2019 avant
même la pandémie et que l'activité
sociale économique culturelle et
sportive a pu reprendre dans notre pays
et les français je crois dans leur
grande majorité ont compris corps
pendant une vague épidémique comme la
vague du variant delta si nous n'avions
pas eu le pass nous aurions été
contraint de fermer un certain nombre
d'établissements et ça ne veulent plus
tueur mature donc aujourd'hui le pass
permet cette garantie l'a1 quand nous
aurons la certitude que le niveau de
vaccination de leurs amplis nécessaire
nous supprimons de lorsque la
circulation virale sera suffisamment
atténuées pour que nous n'ayons plus
besoin de contrôler qui est vacciné qui
ne l'est pas nous les supprimerons je
redis notre volonté farouche de nous
prie de nous passer de cet outil dès que
nous pourrons nous en passer croyez sur
mon engagement mon engagement sur ce
sujet
qu'elle est en fait la stratégie de
l'écrasement pour le sénateur jonnier
qui pose la question au fond que qu'est
ce qu'on vise avec la stratégie il ya
plusieurs possibilités si on en restait
avec un variant comme celui ci avec son
niveau de contagiosité et son niveau de
pathogénicité est-ce qu'il faut procéder
à des rappels de vaccination chez qui
est tous les combien aujourd'hui on sait
que c'est les gens qui sont fragiles par
le rajout par leur maladie et dont le
système immunitaire ne garde pas la
mémoire suffisamment longtemps il faut
un rappel à six mois pour les gens qui
sont plus jeunes aujourd'hui n'y a pas
de recommandations il ya qu israël qui
le fait
parce qu'on sait on sait que le système
immunitaire et plus
on sait que le système immunitaire les
plus matures peut-être qu'avec
l'observer des données à 10 mois 11 mois
12 mois si les données nous montrent que
l'immunité s'affaiblit chez les gens
plus jeunes dans ce cas là on sera amené
à dire aux gens il vous faut un rappel
aujourd'hui c'était pas le cas et mais
ces données ne montre pas mais que nous
permettrait une vaccination massive dans
la durée et contre ce qu vide qui va pas
disparaître de lui même de la planète eh
bien ça il ya plusieurs issue favorable
la première issue favorable c'est une
mutation du virus parce qu'ils
n'arrivent plus trop à circuler il est
contraint emule tu il devient peut être
contagieux mais inactif c'est-à-dire
n'entraînant pas de symptômes et donc on
vit avec comme on vit avec des milliers
et des milliers et des milliers de virus
je rappelle qu'il ya plus de virus dans
une cuillère à soupe d'eau de mer qui
lie à d'européens sur le continent
européen donc on peut rendre ce virus
entre guillemets inactifs par lui-même
grâce à la vaccination qui fait qu'il
n'a plus le voit d'échappatoire
l'autre possibilité c'est que ce soit un
virus qui reviennent de manière
récurrente par vaguelettes et non plus
par vagues et qui ne soit pas plus
dangereux que d'autres virus qu'on
connaît dans le pays comme la grippe par
exemple donc ça c'est la vaccination qui
permettra à ce qu'il faut faire des
rappels ou non tout ça il n'y a que le
temps qui nous permettra de le savoir ça
ce sont les scénarios qui sont positifs
favorables scénarios négatifs auquel
personne ne veut penser évidemment c'est
celui d'une nouvelle mutation avec un
échappement immunitaire au vaccin une
nouvelle circulation et ses stars
aujourd'hui tout nous laisse à penser
que nous avons désormais la maîtrise de
l'épidémie grâce aux outils dont nous
disposons et ces outils là nous savons
que nous en aurons besoin dans les mois
à venir et pas dans les semaines à venir
c'est l'objet de ce projet de loi que
nous dire disons nous les choses en
franchise on met la politique de côté on
met la question des élections de côté on
se dit juste est ce qu'il ya une chance
est ce qu'il ya une chance pour que dans
trois mois la situation soit différente
aujourd'hui la réponse est non est ce
que nous avons aujourd'hui trouver les
bons outils qui permettent d'avoir un
niveau d'équilibré entre les contraintes
et les libertés la réponse est oui est
ce que nous avons su montrer depuis six
mois que désormais même s'il ya une
vague épidémique il n'y a pas d'impact
sanitaire majeur dans notre pays
la réponse est oui est-ce qu'il faut
nous désarmer dans les mois à venir la
réponse est non
dernière question mais il beaucoup de
questions pousser mais c'est intéressant
la fin de la gratuité des tests je les
dis ça fait monter un peu la
primovaccination et on n'a pas du tout
super du suivi de l'épidémie on n'a pas
casser le thermomètre déjà on est à plus
de 2 millions de tests par semaine ce
qui veut dire qu'on est dans la moyenne
haute européenne et d'ailleurs on n'est
plus dans le le comme rejoint la moyenne
européenne en arrive davantage comparer
avec nos voisins ensuite on a pris vous
savez un point au moment juste avant la
fin de la gratuité des tests on avait le
nombre de tests et nombre de cas
positifs ensuite on a enregistré la
baisse du nombre de tests environ 30 %
sur la semaine qui a suivi et donc on a
enregistré une baisse du taux
d'incidence qu'on a vu qu'on avait
anticipé et une semaine plus tard ou
mais un nouveau point sur la courbe on
trace et on reprend la perspective de
l'épidémie donc on n'a absolument pas
perdu les outils de mesure de l'épidémie
et on est à un niveau de tests encore
une fois qui est très ambitieux et je
rappelle que des tests sont gratuits
pour tout le monde sauf si vous n'êtes
pas vacciné vous n'avez pas leur donnant
ce que vous n'êtes pas qu'un contact que
vous ne participez pas une opération
dépistage collectif que vous n'allez pas
dans un barnum et vous n'êtes pas
appeler ni par l'assurance maladie ni
par 10 par la grèce donc on a quand même
à garder un niveau de sécurisation les
outils de mesure d'épidémie qui est bien
plus élevé que chez n'importe lequel de
nos voisins vous remercie chez les jours
nous avons encore plusieurs questions
madame de la gontrie puis madame bof
anti de ça puis monsieur richard puis
monsieur martin devriez et probablement
sur le questeur bas
mais question cours de l'eau à nos
besoins
ça arrive de deux questions qu j'ai
écouté avec beaucoup d'intérêt
je passerai d'avoir tout compris mais
bon du coup de deux questions courtes je
n'ai rien entendu pour que vous
expliquer pourquoi le 31 juillet je
m'explique tous ici
tous ici nous disons nous sommes dans
des groupes parlementaires différents
nous soucier jours jusqu'à fin février
jamais les textes successifs vous l'avez
rappelé on en a eu 11 non prévus des
durées si longue donc
je n'ai pas entendu une seule fois un
argument rationnel
qui explique pourquoi vous voulez aller
au-delà de fin février premièrement
deuxièmement je vous ai écoutés sur la
question de la dose de rappel et de la
validité du pass sanitaire est ce que
j'ai bien entendu qu'en fait vous n'en
savez rien c'est à dire que vous avez
dit j'ai posé la question
mais vous n'avez pas la réponse donc à
l'heure où nous parlons nous nous sommes
bien d'accord que vous ne savez pas dire
si le pass sanitaire restera valide
dans quelles conditions en fonction de
la troisième de la dose de rappel je
suis pas clair voulais je reformule
non ma question si votre imprécisions et
votre incapacité à répondre de manière
claire sur ce point
oui mais si vous savez c'est
si possible on pose des questions et on
répond après parce que le temps tourne
je répète vous avez dit tout à l'heure
et j'ai noté j'ai posé la question
d'accord donc jeu ce qui nous importe
aussi ici c'est de comprendre comment ça
va marcher et donc cette affaire de
passes sanitaires indépendamment du fait
de savoir si on est pour si on est
contre et etc comment est ce que vous
allez incrémenté la question de la dose
de rappel puisque vous avez dit tout à
l'heure j'ai posé la question
oui merci par ailleurs monsieur le
ministre nous ne sommes pas à l'école
donc je fais ce que je veux pendant que
vous parlez mais par ailleurs je peux
vous poser des prévisions sur les
imprécisions s'il vous plaît à les
banaboo chantier
celui d'istres on apprend mais peut-être
en informations étaient erronées et dans
ces conditions pour vous me le direz
mais permettez moi de poursuivre on
apprend que le pass and i ter ne sera
pas obligatoire pour les meetings
politiques
or s'il ya un lieu de libre circulation
et de prolifération du virus c'est bien
quand même dans le meeting politique
enfin le temps en même temps on sait que
le passé maintenant obligatoire aux
enfants qui veulent s'instruire sagement
dans les bibliothèques chacun acier à sa
place en dehors de toute condition d'un
tassement
selon les statistiques officielles
là aussi vous être je me trompe 30 % des
enfants de 12 à 18 ans ne sont pas
vaccinés et ne dispose pas de pass à
lithaire alors on peut se poser la
question pourquoi ne sont ils pas
vacciner peut-être parce que pendant des
mois le discours officiel a été de
marteler que la vaccination des jeunes
étaient inutiles voire contre-productive
avant une soudaine volte face en début
d'été donc nous savons aujourd'hui que
comme le pass est obligatoire pour
accéder dans les espaces culturels et
même sportif je crois
nous constatons qu aujourd'hui 30 %
presque un tiers des jeunes seront
bannis des lieux d'intelligence fait ça
c'est ma déduction elle est peut-être un
peu rapide dans ma question est ce à
dire monsieur le ministre que le meeting
politique mérite plus de considération
que des enfants qui souhaitent
s'instruire merci de votre réponse
précise
merci madame monsieur richard
revient sur le sujet de l'incorporation
de la troisième dose dans
le pass
la question dont vous attendez la
réponse des experts et est-ce qu'il est
pertinent
de faire de la troisième dose une
condition du maintien du pass sanitaires
pour un certain public
je trouve cette question légitime et
nous allons là-bas réponse dans quelques
jours elle sera publiée que le permettra
d'être débattues par tout le monde et
c'est simplement ce qui m'a surpris
c'est quand vous disiez
le
cette incorporation cette inclusion la
troisième dose dans le pass sera
applicable en fonction des pathologies
des gens
si on dit les plus de 65 ans les moins
de 65 ça c'est déjà dans le sait déjà
dont les données du passe donc à aucun
problème pour dire la la troisième dose
devient indispensable pour avoir le pas
si vous avez plus de 65 ans mais si
c'est
aussi elle devient indispensable si vous
êtes en surpoids
je ne préfèrerais que vous nous donner
une réponse un peu par oui ou par non
est ce que on a les données
utilisables dans des conditions pratique
est légale pour bondir modules et
l'inclusion ou non
du de la troisième dose pour le maintien
du pass
si monsieur richard mais chez martin
devriez qui était en visio mais j'ai
l'impression que ça il est là il est là
et là des files a dit merci monsieur le
président merci monsieur le ministre
pour vos réponses très claires merci
aussi d'avoir rappelé plusieurs fois
parce qu'on a tendance à l'oublier que
c'est une pandémie est pas une crise
française et que donc c'est quand des
mines les tous les ressorts que l'on
peut utiliser pour la combattre relève
de sujets qui peuvent être sur le temps
long et parfois sur beaucoup
d'incertitudes une question à travers
tout ça dans les décisions qui avaient
été prises cet été même avant il y avait
la possibilité pour les médecins
généralistes d'accéder aux fichiers de
leur patientèle qui ne seraient pas
vaccinés il semblerait que
malheureusement beaucoup de médecins ne
l'utilisent pas ou que ce soit le
résultat soit très faible est-ce que
vous avez des statistiques à ce sujet là
et est ce qu'on peut imaginer des moyens
pour accélérer ce processus parce que je
pense que la meilleure solution pour
aller vers en particulier les personnes
les plus âgées passent par les médecins
généralistes
un grand merci si monsieur bah merci
monsieur le président je disais tout à
l'heure monsieur le ministre c'est le
moment de vous poser des questions c'est
pas encore le moment du débat mais je
veux réagir sur un point vous nous dites
rien ne permet de penser que la
situation sera différente ou 28 février
de ce qu'elle est aujourd'hui mais enfin
monsieur le ministre la situation n'a
cessé d'évoluer de mois en mois la
situation est-elle la même aujourd'hui
qu'au mois de juillet la réponse est
évidemment non il ya des de
transformation très profonde du contexte
épidémiologique il y a des éléments vous
les avez relevé vous même s'agissant des
nouvelles molécules qui sont sur le
marché qui sont nouveaux les effets de
la vaccination doivent encore être
mesuré dans le temps bien sûr que oui la
situation dans trois mois ne sera pas la
même qu'aujourd'hui est ce que nous
disons nous c'est tout simplement que
nous voulons non pas vous priver de
moyens d'action mais décidée en fonction
d'un contexte si oui ou non nous les
prolongeront et c'est ce que nous avons
toujours fait il n'y a pas de raison que
le sénat adopte une ligne différente de
celle qui correspond à sa cohérence
profonde c'est juste ça mais je crois
pas qu'on puisse vous laisser dire
monsieur le ministre que la situation
sera la même en février car s'il ya une
chose qui est bien certaine c'est
qu'elle sera différente
mais ses ministres juste une seconde je
voudrais rebondir sur la la sphère de la
troisième zone puisqu'on la troisième
dose puisqu'on m'a dit qu'on pouvait pas
l'intégrer immédiatement qu'il fallait
un délai pour pour l'intégrer au pass
sanitaire
comment est ce que vous expliquez ce ce
délai et voilà donc sur la troisième dos
on m'a dit qu'on pouvait pas d'intégrer
immédiatement pas sanitaire qu'il
fallait un certain temps si on intègre
est tout de suite ça risquait de
d'avoir essayé d'avoir un
dysfonctionnement en tous les cas du
logiciel ou de l'upa sanitaire donc est
ce que est ce que c'est bien réglée est
ce qu'il faut vraiment attendre avant
d'intégrer au pass éditeurs / ministre
du jeu au risque d'être désagréable mais
à présent je ne serai pas et quand
madame la sénatrice dit jamais les
textes non prévue de durer si longue
les chiffres sont têtus
sénatrice on a déjà créé proroger le
régime de l'état d'urgence sanitaire
pour 12 mois puis pour neuf mois on a
déjà prorogé le cadre dsi qu'ovide pour
neuf mois donc le texte que nous
présentons aujourd'hui le prolonger de
sept mois et demi donc quand laquelle
assertion qui consiste à dire qu'on n'a
jamais prorogé de façon aussi pour une
durée aussi longue est factuellement
fausse est battue en brèche par les
propres votes émis par les sénateurs eux
mêmes et à plusieurs reprises
la question qui porte sur le droit
électoral là aussi mesdames et messieurs
les sénateurs je vous rappelle que il la
trouve pas lui trouver un équilibre
entre les deux chambres sur le champ
d'application du pass thani terre et
vous avez souhaité dans votre grande
sagesse que ce champ d'application se
réservait aux strictes activités dites
de loisirs j'étais là je me souviens
bien des débats que nous avions à
l'époque le conseil constitutionnel dans
sa grande sagesse des otsi a donc
considéré